meine hypothese ist einfach dass herr
lauterbach tatsächlich und viele andere
politiker links auch und auch viele
leute in der bevölkerung das konzept der
pandemie das konzept der ende mai nicht
verstanden haben die pandemie ist ja
nicht nur vorbei wenn das virus weg ist
weil alle sagen immer um gottes willen
jetzt haben wir jetzt gegen die zahlen
wieder hoch corona ist immer noch da
hört das nicht mal auf nein das hört
nicht auf corona sind nicht die brocken
bei den parcours war es wirklich möglich
einziges ressort war auch bei den
menschen die komplett auszurotten seit
1977 das virus ist weg wenn wir das
kroner hinbekommen dann wäre ich der
erste der sagen würde prima lasst uns
die jede infektion vermeiden jeden
aufwand dazu treiben das funktioniert
aber nicht dass corona wird es ist
gekommen um zu bleiben die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es in zehn
jahren doch hier es ist sehr sehr groß
das heißt wenn wir ein stäbchen bei
menschen in zehn jahren reinstecken dann
wird wahrscheinlich da auch noch saß
kopf zwei dran sein wir müssen uns also
daran gewöhnt dass es da und genau das
bedeutet ja endemische zustand die
pandemie hört dann aber trotzdem auf
warum weil die krankheitslast nicht mehr
da ist und wenn wir warten wollen dieses
virus weg ist dann haben wir pandemie
von jetzt bis zum jahre weiß ich nicht
2035 bis zum termin samstag das kriegen
wir dann nicht mehr weg und dieses
konzept das kann er nicht verstanden
haben denn sonst würde er nicht bei
jedem ansteigen der zahlen gleich wieder
so
alarmistisch reagieren diese ich sage
noch einsatz dazu diese infektionen die
wir jetzt haben so unangenehm sie sind
ich möchte auch nicht haben aber die
haben gar keine wahl so unangenehm sie
sind müssten wir eigentlich fast dankbar
sein dass wir für den winter in der
bevölkerung eine bessere immunität haben
die ja immer besser geworden ist auch
durch die natürlichen infektionen und
die impfung ich möchte die idee
infektion nicht ungeimpft haben das kann
natürlich jeder entscheiden wie er will
aber ich würde sagen auf jeden fall
geimpft und dann darauf die infektion
jeder antigen kontakt hilft diese pa 5
variante das sind jetzt ja momentan
leute die alle geimpft sind oder
genießen sind das heißt wir wissen doch
seit langer zeit dass die impfung und
auch das gewesen sein die infektion an
sich nicht verhindern kann dass klingen
wir auf dauer auch nicht mehr wird herr
lauterbach das verstehen das konzept der
nein also also kann ich mich darauf
freuen dass im herbst endlich mal die
panik nein nein nein das glaube ich auf
gar keinen fall das ist vielleicht noch
nicht mal ein herr lauterbach gebunden
aber so wie ich die sache einschätze
werden im herbst genau die gleiche
situation haben wie bisher wir werden
auch die massen diskussion natürlich
wieder haben möglich ist jetzt genau wie
ist den innenräumen im winter ja
vielleicht durchaus auch sinnvoll nur
dann muss man sich als gesellschaft
einfach überlegen wir haben nicht die
wahl zwischen ganz viel corona und gar
kein corona diese diese variante gibt es
nicht wir müssen tatsächlich was schon
so oft gesagt worden sie sich gar nicht
wir müssen mit dem corona virus leben
und wir können das auch das ist eine
frage des biologischen verständnisses
das was im herbst passiert da bin ich
mich optimistisch
der liberale justizminister buschmann
hat ja gesagt wir machen das jetzt so
wir werden jetzt mal ganz sachlich aus
welche über die erkenntnisse der letzten
zwei jahre aus welche maßnahmen waren
eigentlich in welcher situation ziehen
von studien aus anderen ländern dazu
genau die müssen natürlich einbezogen
und verhältnismäßig und dann wird das im
bundestag evaluiert was man an
erkenntnissen hat und für den herbst
einen plan gemacht ich finde diese ganz
sachlich nüchterne herangehensweisen
raste er davon koreaner bundestag als
nicht nüchtern war naja ich meine es war
für alle zu beginn der pandemie eine
neue situation aber nach einem jahr
nicht da auch die die wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisse waren ja auch am anfang
nicht so da ich kann mich noch erinnern
als es dann irgendwie manchen
bundesländern verboten war nie mehr als
fünf sekunden auf einer parkbank draußen
zu setzen oder gesundheit zu gehen ja
natürlich sinn von 32 dass man weiß ich
das weiß aber natürlich jetzt dass das
völlig das hätte man auch schon damals
wissen kann viele wohnungen haben davor
gewarnt und gesagt zum beispiel man
hätte die hörsaal- und reese die
verordnung aus dem bundesländer waren
zum teil haben ja weil ich so über den
punkt hinweg und jetzt muss das sachlich
mit den erkenntnissen der letzten zwei
jahre auf wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnissen welche maßnahme hat
eigentlich in welch die situation in der
geringeren übertragung der infektion
geführt
diskutiert werden und dann es ist ja
immer eine abwägung es ist immer eine
abwägung deswegen muss am ende des tages
politik muss ich gut beraten lassen
durch schlaue menschen wie sie aber
glauben sie dass man nicht mehr sehen zu
beraten
bescheiden und die bundesländer so weit
in ihrer kompetenz
die partie ist auf grund dieser
erkenntnisse verhältnismäßig und
angemessen welcher situation und dann
auch für transparenz sorgen für die
bürgerinnen und bürger was passiert in
welcher situation das wollen wir wollen
eine bessere kommunikation
wir wollen wissen was wann wie passieren
dass man reichlich
sagte frey dass also das ist dass jeder
dazu das dient ja dazu nur wenn ich weiß
was wirklich was bringt kann ich auch
die größtmögliche freiheit jetzt schon
dass schweden sich besser nicht schlecht
dass geschlossen hat muss dann eine an
und das musst du dein fliese über
sterblichkeit besser als wir eigentlich
weggenommen die daten dann gleich
korrigiert also immer noch jetzt
aber allein die tatsache ist
wenn man noch schlechter als hätten wir
es im märz der hat sich zwanzig habe da
schon artikel geschrieben darüber und
habe schon gesagt was da alles passiert
es ist alles passiert also ich muss
ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen sie kommen aus
ihrer verantwortung nicht raus wir
kennen sie noch so viel reden und es
wird der zeitpunkt kommen wo die
rechnung gemacht wird ok und die
rechnung dessen menschenleben und was da
jetzt passiert ist da raus und haben es
auch angedeutet und und und bezüglich
der psychischen störung selber gesagt
ganzen psychischen wissen sie was dann
passiert das sind nicht einfach
psychische störungen sondern ist eine
psychologische störungen das heißt es
die störung des immunsystems und das ist
der große große wahrscheinlichkeit
wissen das ist ein studien ganz klar
dass die kinder die jetzt so gestresst
wurden und so psychisch krank werden und
so traumatisiert worden dass die jetzt
viel kürzer leben werden wissen sie das
weil zwei jahre lang sollen unfug
gemacht wurde mit menschen die werden
jetzt früher sterben
ganz viel literatur die diese
herrschaften die das sagen haben nicht
gelesen haben bzw auch gar nicht die
medizin ideologie haben solche studien
lesen zu wollen die interessieren sich
gar nicht dafür weil sie die psyche gar
nicht für wichtig halten und ich sage
die psyche so was schon wichtig und das
sozial und das kulturelle ist in der
gesundheit und der krankheit so was
schon wichtig dass wir jetzt mit ganz
schlimmen zahlen rechnen werden in den
nächsten zehn 20 30 40 50 jahren denn
die kinder die jetzt traumatisiert
wurden die werden ihre schweren
entzündungserkrankungen kriegen weil das
immunsystem gestört ist weil sie aus
diesen situationen nicht rauskommen wenn
man gar nicht das geld mehr und
psychosozial kultur therapie zu
betreiben dh diese kinder werden jetzt
sehr kranke an langfristig das ist jetzt
meine prognose und schweden wird das
modell schlechthin sein nach denen sich
dann alle richten werden und sagen wenn
mensch hätten wir das gewusst ja sie
haben es gewusst okay sie haben nach
zwei monaten bereits gewusst des
schweden anders läuft jeder hat dort
hingeguckt und hat schlecht gemacht
schweiz hat es ein bisschen anders
gemacht südkorea ein bisschen anders
gemacht das waren bereits experimente
der kultur dieser stadt wir auch in
deutschland die längsten insgesamt
längsten absolut beste vorgehensweise
gegenüber menschen und das wird sich
rechnen und ich nochmal die
verantwortung werden sie tragen müssen
da kommen sie nicht raus das können sie
jetzt verharmlosen aber nichts gesagt
haben nein ich habe nicht vor mich ich
habe gesagt das passt jetzt hier muss
sein dass wir lockdown dieser art für
die zukunft verhindern ich habe selber
gesagt welche gravierenden chinas hat
und aus meiner sicht das nicht im
verhältnis steht zudem schutz der
gewährleistet werden nein ich wir können
uns das gleiche sagen sie auch der die
impfungen die die sind die machen
krankheitsverläufe besser keine studie
existiert für sowas sind dahra tief dass
eine
sterilität ich würde nicht die
behauptung dass die impfstoffe
den kann ich vielleicht nicht verbessern
also das würde ich so nicht
unterschreiben jetzt mit der sterilität
ist natürlich richtig in der
kommunikation übrigens hatte experten
hat was auch angemahnt dass das getrennt
wird politische kommunikation und
gesundheitskommunikation daran glaube
ich überhaupt nicht dass das geschehen
wird da ist viel schief gelaufen zum
beispiel hat man hinterher dann gesagt
ja eine sterile immunität war ja nie
angedacht doch waren und vielleicht wäre
dies sogar gekommen wenn sich das virus
also in seiner ursprungswerte nie
verändert hätte aber das hat es
natürlich getan und deswegen ist auch
der jetzt anstehende omikron spezifische
impfstoff ganz nett aber da braucht
wirklich niemand darauf warten denn
dieser weg ohnehin stoff der ist ja auch
nicht angepasst auf die a4 und a5
sondern natürlich auch das ursprungs
omikron und wenn jeder sagt lauterbach
selbst jetzt im september frühestens
also da braucht keiner drauf warten der
alte ist gut genug dafür ich gehe jetzt
nicht so ganz damit wird sie nicht
verwundern dass die impfung nichts
bringen würde
es gibt schon studien die sehr wohl auch
mit kontrollgruppen langmann die dann
noch nicht hat impfen können zeigen kann
dass die verläufe doch milder sind ich
gebe ihnen zur mikro noch nicht genau um
diesen genau stehe genau jetzt kommen
wir zum mikro da kann es ihnen
tatsächlich nicht beweisen bei delta
ja also ich würde wenn sie mich jetzt
fragen kannst du dich hier hinstellen
und sagen auch in zehn jahren werden wir
nie sehen dass irgendwas an dieser
impfung nicht gut war kann ich nicht ich
glaube allerdings nicht weil viele leute
ja immer darauf abheben auf das neue
prinzip m rna dass das gefährlich wäre
ich glaube da muss man gar nicht drauf
abheben weil wenn eine impfung in der
vergangenheit bisher irgendwas nicht
wünschenswertes gebracht hat also ich
denke mal ein pandemrix die pandemie
impfung bei der
krippe damals da hat ja diese
narkolepsie diese schlafend werden gegen
die grippe schweinegrippe das waren
antikörper die im körper gegen
körpereigene strukturen neben
schlaf-wach-rhythmus angegriffen haben
so viel weiß man heute davon und das
heißt antikörper ist ja das was am ende
jeglicher impfung egal mit welchem
prinzip liches mache stehe das heißt
selbst wenn ich irgendein anderer
impfung habe dann kann ich das pech
haben dass diese antikörper nicht nur
das machen was sie sollen also das virus
bekämpfen sondern bei irgendwelchen
menschen irgendwelche eigenen
körpereigene strukturen angreifen das
heißt ich muss gar nicht abheben auf das
auf das neue prinzip deswegen sehe es
nicht ganz so kritisch
wie sie aber ich gebe ihnen auf jeden
fall insoweit recht dass wir mit viel
mehr augenmaß da hätten daran gehen
müssen und das musste man in der tat
schon vor zwei jahren weil es die welt
ist nicht nur virus sind dann gelesen
besser geschützt als gm diese frage
stellen sich ja auch die immunität der
genesenen hat eine israelische studie
jetzt ganz schön gezeigt hält etwas
länger an als die bei den geimpften
ideal scheint zu sein das sagt doch herr
torsten willmann geimpft ist gepustet
und dann eine infektion im dorfe was ist
das das ist immer wieder kontakt mit
antigenen und wir werden gar nicht umhin
kommen als uns immer wieder dem antigen
auszusetzen ob wir das wollen oder nicht
wie gesagt ich setze mich hin und sage
corona ist völlig harmlos und nur hier
ist schon bald nicht getan sagt er das
nicht die sprachgrenzen
ist da ja dass das bleibt auch da und
wenn ihr das mal kapiert haben es ist
nicht der die unterscheidung zwischen
paradies und hölle sondern zwischen pest
und cholera dazwischen müssen wir uns
entscheiden und da ist es besser wir
lassen auch diese infektionen zu wo wir
sie guten gewissens zu lassen können ja
das heißt es werden auch weiterhin leute
sterben so ehrlich muss man sein aber
die sterben auch an wir alle auch an
anderen infektion eine infektion steht
am lebensende leider sehr sehr häufig
jetzt sind es eben häufig menschen die
korona haben also positiven befund aber
dass wir zum beispiel das mich noch
sagen dass wir auf die intensivstation
immer noch nicht unterscheiden können im
ganzen krankenhaus nicht unterscheiden
können wer jetzt da wirklich wie corona
liegt oder mit corona natürlich sterben
jetzt auch leute mit krone das war auch
vorher dass wir im winter auch wieder
verstärkt sein dann heißt es immer ja
das kann man medizinisch nicht so
auseinander dividieren ja es gibt solche
fälle wo es wirklich schwierig ist aber
man könnte es wesentlich besser machen
als wir es tun die engländer können es
auch da können wir uns was abschalten